I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Surprise! It's Friday.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。惊喜吧！今天是星期五。
It's not Wednesday. We're hitting your feed. On a Friday! On a Friday! B-G-I-F! We have a way to celebrate. We hope you like it. We are going to play for you the entire first chapter of our audiobook of The Office BFFs.
今天不是星期三。我们在你的动态里出现啦。在星期五！在星期五！B-G-I-F！我们有一个庆祝的方式。希望你们会喜欢。我们将为你播放我们的有声书《办公室闺蜜》的第一章完整内容。
So happy Friday. Hang out with us for a little bit and we hope you have a great weekend. Chapter one. Job opening. Officework. In 2003, a group of strangers had one very big thing in common. We had all just been cast on a new TV comedy pilot called The Office. After years of living as struggling artists, we were all very happy to be employed in doing
所以祝大家周五快乐。和我们一起消磨一会儿时光，希望你们有个美好的周末。第一章。职位空缺。办公室工作。2003年，一群陌生人有一个非常共同的巨大特点。我们当时都刚被选中出演一部名为《办公室》的新喜剧电视剧试播集。经过多年苦苦挣扎的艺术家生活，我们都非常高兴能有工作做，
what we loved. We could never have predicted the impact it would have on the rest of our lives. I have an old photo from my first day of work on The Office. It was taken when Steve Carell, John Krasinski, Rainn Wilson, BJ Novak, David Denman, Phyllis Smith and I met with the producers, network executives, showrunner Greg Daniels, and director Ken Qwapis to do a table read of the pilot script for the very first time. Allison Jones, our casting director, came to the table read armed with a plate of homemade chocolate chip cookies and a Polaroid camera.
做我们热爱的事。我们绝不会预料到它会对我们的余生产生什么样的影响。我有一张我第一天在《办公室》工作的旧照片。那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、约翰·卡拉辛斯基、雷恩·威尔逊、B·J·诺瓦克、大卫·丹曼、菲莉丝·史密斯和我与制片人、电视网高管、剧集运作人格雷格·丹uels以及导演肯·ク瓦皮斯见面，第一次进行试播集剧本围读时拍的。艾莉森·琼斯，我们的选角导演，带着一盘自制巧克力豆曲奇和一台拍立得相机来到了围读现场。
I desperately wanted a picture to commemorate the day, and this was before everyone had cameras on their phones. So I was excited when she told us all to gather together for a photo. I asked if she would take one for me, too. She said sure, took a second picture, and handed me the Polaroid and a cookie. I remember standing and munching the cookie while watching the photo slowly develop before my eyes. To let you know how special this whole moment was, let me share a little about my backstory.
我非常想要一张照片来纪念这一天，而在那之前并不是每个人手机都有相机。所以当她叫我们大家聚在一起拍张照时，我很兴奋。我问她能不能也帮我拍一张。她说当然可以，拍了第二张照片，然后把拍立得照片和一块曲奇交给了我。我记得自己一边站着嚼曲奇，一边看着照片在我眼前慢慢显影。为了让你知道整个时刻有多么特别，让我分享一点我的背景故事。
I grew up in St. Louis, Missouri. From the time I was seven years old, I knew I wanted to be an actor. I can't say why exactly, but I barely remember a time when this wasn't my goal. At age nine, I considered becoming a veterinarian, but when I learned I would have to do surgeries on animals, I went back to my original plan of actor. My parents were very supportive, but also refused to let me act professionally as a child. And it's not like there were a ton of opportunities in St. Louis, to be honest. They told me I had to graduate from high school and college before moving to Los Angeles.
我在密苏里州圣路易斯长大。从七岁起，我就知道我想成为一名演员。我不能确切说出为什么，但我几乎记不起这不是我目标的时期了。九岁时，我曾考虑过成为一名兽医，但当我得知我必须对动物做手术时，我又回到了最初当演员的计划。我的父母非常支持我，但也拒绝让我小时候就以专业演员身份演戏。说实话，圣路易斯也没有成吨的机会。他们告诉我，我必须高中和大学毕业后才能搬到洛杉矶。
So I auditioned for every school play and joined every drama club. I spent most of high school in the dancing chorus, until my senior year when I was cast as the fiddler in The Fiddler on the Roof. I had no lines, but extra solo dancing. I went to college at a small liberal arts school in rural Missouri called Truman State University and majored in theater. I learned a lot about acting technique and my love of performing was solidified. After graduation, I packed up my Mazda 323 hatchback and drove across the country to Los
所以我去试镜了每一个学校话剧并加入了每一个戏剧社。我的高中大部分时间都在舞蹈合唱团度过，直到高三时我被选中在《屋顶上的提琴手》中扮演提琴手。我没有台词，但有额外的独舞。我去了密苏里州乡村的一所小型文理学校——杜鲁门州立大学读大学，主修戏剧。我学到了很多关于表演技巧的知识，我对表演的热爱也得到了巩固。毕业后，我收拾好我的马自达323两厢车，开车横跨全国来到洛
Angeles, ready to give it a go in Hollywood. I ended up spending years in various odd jobs trying to pay off my defaulted credit card and make my rent. Thanks to a mandatory typing class in high school, most of the jobs I found were working as, wait for it, a receptionist. In the meantime, I was going on hundreds of auditions and performing Comedia Del Arte with a local theater company. I earned my Screen Actors Guild card doing background work, experience that would come
杉矶，准备在好莱坞闯一闯。我最终花了几年时间做各种零工，试图还清我违约的信用卡并支付房租。多亏了高中时的一堂必修打字课，我找到的大多数工作都是——你猜怎么着——前台。与此同时，我和一个当地戏剧公司一起参加了数百次试演并表演意大利即兴喜剧。我通过做背景演员拿到了影视演员工会卡，这段经验后来会派上
in handy later as you will learn in this book, and each year I seemed to do a little better than the year before. I booked some guest appearances on television shows, a couple of independent films, and a pilot called Rubbing Charlie. Yes, you heard that right. It was a comedy, starring a stressed out doctor named Charlie, played by Scott Wolf, who gets life lessons from his massage therapist, me. I actually rubbed Charlie.
用场，正如你在本书中将了解到的那样，而且每年我似乎都比前一年做得好一点。我在电视节目中预订了一些客串演出，几部独立电影，以及一部名为《揉搓查理》的试播集。是的，你没听错。那是一部喜剧，由斯科特·沃尔夫饰演的一个压力山大的医生查理为主演，他从他的按摩师（也就是我）那里得到生活教训。我真的揉搓了查理。
It was a really sweet and funny show. I was convinced it would be my big break. So when it didn't make it past the pilot stage, I was crushed. I told my manager I wanted to quit, the years of rejection having taken their toll, and my new plan was to apply to vet technician school, Animal Care, with no surgeries. She told me to keep at it that the right role would find me if I just didn't give up. I had my doubts. At that point, I'd been plugging away in Los Angeles for nearly eight years, but I decided
那是一部非常甜美有趣的剧。我确信这将是我的重大突破。所以当它没能通过试播阶段时，我心碎了。我告诉经纪人我想辞职，多年的拒绝已经让我付出了代价，我的新计划是申请兽医技术学校，动物护理，不需要做手术。她告诉我坚持下去，只要我不放弃，对的角色就会找到我。我对此表示怀疑。那时，我在洛杉矶已经打拼了近八年，但我决定
to take her advice and give it one more year. As fate would have it, the following pilot season, I was asked to audition for the American remake of a BBC show called The Office. The role was for the receptionist, Pam, a worn down yet still hopeful young woman with artistic dreams beyond her depressing day job. In other words, me. After we snapped the shot, Steve Carell said, one day this photo will be worth money, especially after they fire me and replace me with a new actor for episode two.
听从她的建议，再试一年。正如命运安排的那样，在接下来的试播季，我被邀请去为BBC节目《办公室》的美版翻拍进行试演。这个角色是前台潘，一个精疲力竭却依然充满希望的年轻女性，有着超越她令人沮丧的白领工作的艺术梦想。换句话说，就是我。我们拍完照后，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说，总有一天这张照片会很值钱，尤其是等他们炒了我并找一个新演员来演第二集之后。
You'll all look at this and say, ah, remember Steve, what's his name? He was sweet. I wonder what he's up to now. Before The Office, Steve had the most experience of all of us. He wasn't a household name by any means, but he had been a correspondent on The Daily Show. He'd been a regular on the Dana Carvey show, and he'd had a scene stealing role opposite Jim Carrey in the movie Bruce Almighty.
你们都会看着这个说，啊，还记得史蒂夫，他叫什么来着？他真讨人喜欢。不知道他现在在忙什么。在《办公室》之前，史蒂夫是我们当中经验最丰富的。他绝不是家喻户晓的名字，但他曾是《每日秀》的记者。他曾是《达纳·卡维秀》的常驻演员，并且在电影《冒牌天神》中与金·凯瑞演对手戏时有一个抢戏的角色。
He had also been rejected by Saturday Night Live and been cast in more than one failed pilot. He knew better than all of us how rough and random our business could be. Rainn Wilson had been knocking around for about 10 years, traveling the country doing Shakespeare and most recently worked as a recurring character on Six Feet Under. Phyllis had spent the previous 19 years working in casting, including eight as a casting associate for Alison Jones. When we all came in to audition for The Office, Phyllis was our reader.
他也曾被《周六夜生活》拒绝，并出演过不止一部失败的试播集。他比我们所有人都清楚我们的行业有多残酷和随机。雷恩·威尔逊已经在周围摸爬滚打大约10年了，在全国各地巡演莎士比亚戏剧，最近作为常驻角色在《六尺之下》工作。菲莉丝过去19年一直在选角行业工作，其中八年担任艾莉森·琼斯的选角助理。当我们所有人都来为《办公室》试演时，菲莉丝是我们的读词人。
Ken Qwapis was so taken with her, he told showrunner Greg Daniels he thought she should play a role on the show. John Krasinski had done some commercials, and like me, his last pilot was not picked up. B.J. Novak had been doing stand-up comedy when Greg discovered him. David Denman was like Steve. He'd been an employed yet mostly unknown actor for years, having appeared in a number
肯·ク瓦皮斯对她印象深刻，他告诉剧集运作人格雷格·丹尼斯，他认为她应该在剧中扮演一个角色。约翰·卡拉辛斯基拍过一些广告，和我一样，他上一部试播集没有被选中。B·J·诺瓦克在格雷格发现他之前一直在做单口喜剧。大卫·丹曼就像史蒂夫。他多年来一直是一个有工作但基本上默默无闻的演员，出演过许多
of studio films and miniseries. He'd also done four pilots, none of which ever made it to series. We all laughed at Steve's joke, but the truth is, we were all also secretly wondering if we'd get to episode two. Also there that day were the creators of the original version of The Office, Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant. I had watched every episode of the British series and naturally was a huge fan. I was in awe of Lucy Davis' portrayal of Dawn, Pam's British counterpart.
制片厂电影和迷你剧。他还拍过四部试播集，但没有一部进入剧集制作。我们都对史蒂夫的笑话笑了，但事实是，我们大家也都暗自琢磨着自己能不能撑到第二集。那天在那里的人还有原版《办公室》的创作者瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特。我看过这部英国剧集的每一集，自然是个超级粉丝。我为露西·戴维斯对道恩（潘的英国版角色）的塑造感到惊叹。
She could communicate so much with just a glance. I hoped that I could bring as much heart and depth to Pam as Lucy did to Dawn. As I sat with the creators of this masterpiece, I remember thinking, if I lose this job tomorrow, at least I got to sit in the same room as Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant. After the read, Ricky and Steven gave us ideas for how to best Americanize the show. This had been the subject of a lot of discussion amongst the creative team. In England, they do much shorter television seasons. The original office series was only 12 episodes long in total with one Christmas special.
她仅仅通过一个眼神就能传达如此多的信息。我希望我能为潘带来和露西为道恩带来的一样多的心意和深度。当我与这部杰作的创作者坐在一起时，我记得我想过，如果我明天失去这份工作，至少我曾和瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特坐在同一个房间里。读完剧本后，瑞奇和斯蒂芬为我们如何最好地将该剧美式本土化提出了建议。这一直是创作团队中大量讨论的主题。在英国，他们的电视播出季要短得多。原版办公室剧集总共只有12集，外加一个圣诞特别节目。
American networks expect a lot more than that. A typical American television show makes 24 episodes per season. Ricky noted that if we hoped to make 100 episodes, we should be sure people didn't become too frustrated by Michael's incompetence. He suggested we make him a buffoon but still good at his job. That way, American viewers would find something to admire in Michael amidst all the annoyance. Steven Merchant then said that the gym and Pam relationship was another way to balance Michael's obnoxious behavior.
美国电视网的期望要高得多。一部典型的美国电视剧每季制作24集。瑞奇指出，如果我们希望制作100集，我们应该确保人们不会对迈克尔的无能感到过于沮丧。他建议我们把他塑造成一个滑稽可笑但依然工作出色的人。这样一来，美国观众就会在所有的烦恼中发现迈克尔身上值得钦佩的地方。斯蒂芬·莫昌特随后表示，吉姆和潘的关系是平衡迈克尔讨厌行为的另一种方式。
He said, always remember, gym and Pam are the heart of the show. Gulp, no pressure. I did not grow up in Los Angeles either. I grew up in Indonesia by way of Louisiana and Texas. My dad was a drilling engineer and we moved around for his job. I always knew I wanted to be a performer. My mom loves to tell the story about when she asked me and my older sisters what we wanted to be when we grew up.
他说，永远记住，吉姆和潘是节目的核心。咽口水，没有压力。我也不是在洛杉矶长大的。我经由路易斯安那州和德克萨斯州在印度尼西亚长大。我爸爸是一名钻井工程师，我们因为他的工作四处搬迁。我一直都知道我想成为一名表演者。我妈妈很喜欢讲这样一个故事：当她问我和大姐姐们长大了想做什么时，
All my sisters had funny responses but mine, she said, was the most puzzling. My sister, Billy, said she wanted to be, quote, the boss. Janet wanted to be a truck driver like our uncle Carl, Tina, a gymnast. And I wanted to be Carol Burnett. I was four. My dad had shown me the Carol Burnett show and all I wanted to do for the rest of my life was be a comedian. My first big break was getting cast as Mary in the Christmas play at school.
我所有的姐姐都有搞笑的回答，但她说我的最令人费解。我姐姐比利说她想当“老板”，引号。珍妮想和我们的叔叔卡尔一样当卡车司机，蒂娜想当体操运动员。而我想当卡罗尔·伯内特。我当时四岁。我爸爸带我看了《卡罗尔·伯内特秀》，我余生想做的全部事情就是当个喜剧演员。我的第一个重大突破是被选中在学校的圣诞话剧里扮演玛丽。
Not a lot of jokes were written for Mary, but hey, it was a lead role. During college, I would write stand-up bits and try them out for my friends. I had grown up watching David Letterman's monologues and would even memorize some of his routines. I was desperate to learn more about comedy writing and after four years at Baylor University and a bachelor's degree, I headed to New York City to intern for a late night with Conan O'Brien. When I interviewed for my position on Conan, I was told only two interns were ever on the
没有为玛丽写很多笑话，但嘿，这是一个主角。在大学期间，我会写单口喜剧段子并在朋友面前试用。我从小看着大卫·莱特曼的独白长大，甚至会背诵他的一些常规节目。我极度渴望了解更多关于喜剧写作的知识，在贝勒大学度过四年并获得学士学位后，我前往纽约市在《柯南·奥布莱恩深夜秀》实习。当我面试我在柯南的职位时，我被告知在排练和录制期间，舞台上只有两个实习生，
stage during rehearsals and tapings, the writer's intern and the band's intern. All the other interns were up in the offices. I was determined to have access to those rehearsals. That's where Conan and Andy Richter and the writers would work out his stand-up routine and sketches. Well, the writer's intern position had already been filled, so I told them I wanted to be the band's intern. They asked me if I knew anything about music.
编剧实习生和乐队实习生。所有其他实习生都在办公室里。我决心要能接触到那些排练。那是柯南、安迪·里奇特和编剧们打磨他的单口喜剧和喜剧小品的地方。嗯，编剧实习生的职位已经满了，所以我告诉他们我想当乐队的实习生。他们问我是否懂任何音乐。
I lied and said, of course, music is my life! I got the job and learned that if you make a friend at SIR, Studio Instrument Rentals, you can fake it until you make it as a music intern. I spent my weekdays watching Conan and my weekends taking acting classes. A friend of mine had given me Uda Hagen's book, A Challenge for the Actor, and I was lucky enough to take a workshop from Carol Rosenfeld at the acting school started by Uda Hagen herself, H.B. Studio. Watching Conan and studying at H.B. Studio boosted my confidence and I decided to move
我撒谎说，当然，音乐就是我的生命！我得到了这份工作，并且了解到如果你在SIR（乐器租赁工作室）交个朋友，你就可以在音乐实习生的岗位上不懂装懂直至驾轻就熟。我工作日看柯南，周末上表演课。我的一个朋友给了我乌达·哈根的书《演员的挑战》，我很幸运能在由乌达·哈根本人创立的表演学校HB工作室参加卡罗尔·罗斯芬尔德的工作坊。看柯南和在HB工作室学习增强了我的信心，我决定搬
to Los Angeles to try to be a television actor. At this point, I was working two jobs and auditioning constantly. I had had a string of national commercials, most notably for Buick, Chrysler, and Lays Wow! Chips with O'Lestra. Yes, the chips that gave everyone abdominal cramping, diarrhea, and anal leakage. Between auditions, I was an operator at 1-800-DENTIST and ran the intern program at the iOS Comedy Club.
到洛杉矶尝试成为一名电视演员。此时，我身兼两职，不断试镜。我拍过一系列全国性广告，最著名的是别克、克莱斯勒以及含有奥利司他的乐事美味薯片！是的，那种让每个人都腹部痉挛、腹泻和肛门漏气的薯片。在试镜间隙，我是1-800-DENTIST的一名接线员，并运营着iOS喜剧俱乐部的实习生项目。
I had been performing improv three nights a week for a decade. You know that annoying friend who was constantly handing you a flyer for their show? That was me. During this time, I was married to Warren Lieberstein and related by marriage to Greg Daniels. Greg and his wife, Suzanne, Warren's sister, were always very supportive and came to several of my shows. In the summer of 2003, Suzanne invited us over for a swim.
我连续十年每周表演三次即兴喜剧。你知道那个总是塞给你一张他们的演出传单的讨厌朋友吗？那就是我。在此期间，我嫁给了沃伦·利伯斯坦，并且通过婚姻与格雷格·丹尼斯有了亲戚关系。格雷格和他的妻子苏珊（沃伦的姐姐）一直非常支持我，并观看了我的好几场演出。2003年夏天，苏珊邀请我们去游泳。
I coveted these afternoon swims because our tiny apartment had only one AC window unit and summers were rough. I had wedged myself into one of their daughter's brightly colored floaties and was trying to paddle to the steps of the pool when Greg sat down to chat. He told us he was going to be remaking the BBC version of The Office. I remember trying to suppress a uh-oh look on my face. A few other major networks tried to bring BBC shows to the United States and failed. The sensibility and tone of a show for a British audience had not transferred well to an American
我垂涎这些下午的游泳时光，因为我们的小公寓只有一个空调窗机，夏天很难熬。我把自己塞进他们女儿色彩鲜艳的浮力圈里，正试图划向游泳池的台阶时，格雷格坐下来聊天。他告诉我他要翻拍BBC版的《办公室》。我记得当时正试图压抑脸上“哦噢”的表情。其他几位主要的电视网曾试图把BBC节目带到美国但都失败了。英国观众的节目感性和基调并没有很好地转化给美国
audience. I loved the BBC version of The Office and was worried that making it for an American audience would be a disaster. But I also felt that if anyone could pull it off, it would be Greg. He had been writing and producing on hit television shows for years and had won several awards for Saturday Night Live, The Simpsons, and a show he co-created, King of the Hill. Greg is one of the most brilliantly funny people you will ever meet on a set or off. He suggested I come in and audition because he thought that my improv background would
观众。我喜欢BBC版的《办公室》，并担心为美国观众制作它会是一场灾难。但我也觉得如果有人能成功的话，那一定是格雷格。他多年来一直在热门电视剧中担任编剧和制片人，并为《周六夜生活》、《辛普森一家》以及他参与创作的节目《山丘之王》赢得过多个奖项。格雷格是你在片场或片场外遇到的最才华横溢、最有趣的人之一。他建议我来试镜，因为他认为我的即兴表演背景会
lend itself to the mockumentary style of the show. Plus, he wanted to use as many unknown actors as he could. Greg felt that the world of a small paper company in Scranton, Pennsylvania would feel more organic if there were no big Hollywood names in the mix. I was definitely not a big Hollywood name, unless Les Wow Potato Chip Lady counted. I was very excited for the opportunity, but also incredibly nervous. Greg told me he would put my name on the list to audition but with one caveat. No one could know that we were related.
很适合该剧的伪纪录片风格。另外，他想尽可能多地使用不知名的演员。格雷格觉得，宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿一家小型纸业公司的世界，如果没有好莱坞大咖的参与，会显得更自然。我绝对不是好莱坞大咖，除非乐事美味薯片女郎算数。我为这个机会感到非常兴奋，但也无比紧张。格雷格告诉我，他会将我的名字写在试镜名单上，但有一个条件。没有人能知道我们有亲戚关系。
Greg felt strongly that letting this information get out to the network would only hurt my chances. We decided that we would not acknowledge each other at the audition. He could get me in the room, but I had to win the room over on my own. I later learned that this ruse was Allison Jones' idea. She was a big champion of mine and had told Greg this was the best plan. Thank you, Allison! On November 17, 2003, I auditioned for the role of Pam.
格雷格坚决认为，让电视网知道这个消息只会损害我的机会。我们决定在试镜时假装不认识对方。他能把我弄进房间，但我必须靠自己赢得房间的认可。我后来得知这个计谋是艾莉森·琼斯的想法。她一直是我的坚定支持者，并告诉格雷格这是最好的计划。谢谢你，艾莉森！2003年11月17日，我为潘的角色进行了试镜。
Yep, fact! I signed into the audition at 2.40pm and was the 16th person that day to read for the role of our favorite receptionist. I know this not because I have an amazing memory, but because the incredible Allison Jones saved my audition sign-in sheet. When the series wrapped nine years later, she gave it to me as a farewell gift. I ugly cried, of course. I treasure owning this piece of my life history.
是的，千真万确！我在下午2点40分签到参加试镜，是那天第16个为我们最喜欢的 receptionist（前台）这个角色试读的人。我知道这一点不是因为我有着惊人的记忆力，而是因为难以置信的艾莉森·琼斯保留了我的试镜签到表。九年后剧集杀青时，她把它作为告别礼物送给了我。我当然是丑哭的。我非常珍惜拥有我这段人生历史的物件。
So many amazing people were there on that same day. Every female comedian I knew went in for the role of Pam. I remember my audition very clearly. It's weird how the brain captures the biggest moments of your life and slows them down. Every single detail is stuck in my brain. I wore a pink sweater and a black pencil skirt. I had worked really hard to prepare my scenes. I waited in a very small room before my audition.
那天有那么多优秀的人也在场。我认识的每一个女性喜剧演员都去竞争潘的角色。我把我的试镜记得清清楚楚。大脑捕捉你人生中最重大时刻并将其放慢的方式真是奇怪。每一个细节都卡在我的脑海里。我穿着一件粉红色的毛衣和一条黑色铅笔裙。我为了准备我的场景付出了很多努力。我在试镜前的一个非常小的房间里等待。
Catherine Hahn was sitting on a sofa in the corner. We smiled at each other and said hello. She is a doll and so talented, I tried my best not to get anxious. I am not sweaty by nature. I usually run cold no matter the temperature, but as it got closer to my turn, I really began to sweat. I actually went into the bathroom and dabbed toilet paper in my armpits. Sorry for the overshare, but that's how nervous I was.
凯瑟琳·哈恩正坐在角落的沙发上。我们相视一笑并打了招呼。她是个甜心而且非常有才华，我尽最大努力不让自己焦虑。我天生不出汗。无论温度如何，我通常都很怕冷，但随着轮到我的时间越来越近，我真的开始出汗了。我甚至去了洗手间，用卫生纸擦了擦腋窝。抱歉分享得太多，但我当时就是那么紧张。
When it was finally my time, I walked into a room full of producers. There was a camera on a tripod and sitting beside the camera was the casting associate, Phyllis, my future party planning committee rival. I was to read with her. Greg was sitting in the very back of the room and neither of us made eye contact. My agent told me they were having everyone read two scenes, but if they liked you, they asked you to do a third. Phyllis and I read my first two scenes and everyone was laughing, it felt great.
终于轮到我时，我走进了挤满制片人的房间。房间里有一台架在三脚架上的摄像机，坐在摄像机旁边的是选角助理菲莉丝，我未来的聚会策划委员会死敌。我要和她对词。格雷格坐在房间的最里面，我们俩都没有眼神交流。我的经纪人告诉我，他们让每个人都读两个场景，但如果他们喜欢你，就会要求你演第三个。菲莉丝和我读了我的前两个场景，大家都笑了，感觉棒极了。
Then I was asked to do a third. I worked hard to contain my excitement. Phyllis and I began the final scene, the one where Michael fake fires Pam in front of Ryan the temp. To jog your memory, in the scene, Michael wants to prank Pam by pretending to fire her for stealing post-it notes. The fake firing goes terribly wrong and Pam is very upset. She starts to cry and calls Michael a jerk.
然后我被要求演第三个。我努力压抑着自己的兴奋。菲莉丝和我开始了最后一个场景，也就是迈克尔在临时工瑞恩面前假装解雇潘的那个场景。为了唤醒你的记忆，在这个场景中，迈克尔想通过假装因为潘偷便利贴而解雇她来恶作剧。这场假解雇大错特错，潘非常难过。她开始哭泣并称迈克尔是个混蛋。
The scene was going well, Phyllis was killing it as Michael. Imagine someone with Phyllis' sweet face smugly telling you that you've been punked. When we got to the part where I was supposed to tear up and call Michael a jerk, I really let Michael slash Phyllis have it. Now, there are three times you can tell I am from Texas. When I am tired, tipsy or pissed off, so I definitely slipped into a southern drawl as I growled, jerk. The room of producers burst out laughing and I remember thinking, hmm, not so sure I'm
场景进行得很顺利，菲莉丝作为迈克尔简直绝了。想象一下，一个有着菲莉丝那样甜美脸庞的人，洋洋得意地告诉你，你被整蛊了。当我们演到我应该流泪并称迈克尔为混蛋的那部分时，我真的对迈克尔/菲莉丝不客气了。现在，有三次你可以看出我是德克萨斯人：当我累了、微醺了或被惹火了，所以我咆哮着“混蛋”时，我绝对带上了南部腔调。制片人房间里的人爆发出大笑，我记得当时想，嗯，不太确定我这时候该得到笑声，但好吧。
supposed to get a laugh at this point, but okay. And that was it. Allison thanked me for coming in. Greg discreetly smiled from the back row and gave me a thumbs up and I walked out of there on cloud nine. I just knew I had that part. The next day, I got a call from Allison. I did not get that part.
就是这样。艾莉森感谢我来参加。格雷格在后排低调地微笑并向我竖起了大拇指，我踩着九霄云外的步伐走出了那里。我只知道我拿到了那个角色。第二天，我接到了艾莉森的电话。我没有得到那个角色。
She told me they really liked me but thought I was a little too feisty for Pam. I was disappointed, of course, but I felt good about my audition and I was thankful for the opportunity. So, I let it go and I moved on. That's just what you have to do as an actor. Plus, I had another audition that week for an improv pilot that I was really excited about. It was about a group of people working at a hair salon in New York City for the Oxygen
她告诉我他们真的很喜欢我，但觉得我演潘有点太好强了。我当然很失望，但我觉得我的试镜表现不错，而且我很感激有这个机会。所以，我放下了，继续前行。作为一个演员，你必须这样做。另外，我那周还有另一个即兴试播集的试镜，我对此非常兴奋。那是关于一群在纽约市一家美发沙龙工作的人，为氧气
Network. The working title was Salon Royale. I auditioned for the role of the promiscuous receptionist. Feisty was no problem here and I was cast. The producers of that show flew me out to New York City first class. I had never flown first class for work and it felt so fancy. The cast was full of amazing improvisers, Ian Roberts, Beth Cahill, Dave Rzalski, and the show was written and directed by Emmy Leiborn.
电视台制作的。暂定名为《皇家沙龙》。我试演了放荡前台的角色。好强在这里完全不是问题，我被选上了。那个节目的制片人用头等舱把我飞到了纽约市。我从来没有因为工作坐过头等舱，感觉太高档了。演员阵容里全都是优秀的即兴演员：伊恩·罗伯茨、贝丝·卡希尔、戴夫·热扎尔斯基，该剧由埃米·莱伯恩编剧和导演。
Emmy's mom, Geraldine, was the president of Oxygen at the time, so I thought we had a good shot of making it to series. But alas, we didn't get picked up. So back to Los Angeles, I went. After back-to-back rejections, I was feeling pretty discouraged about acting. I decided to concentrate my energy on writing and put acting on hold for a while. Several weeks went by and I was feeling good about my decision to lean into writing. And then I got a call that changed everything.
埃米的妈妈杰拉丁当时是氧气电视台的总裁，所以我以为我们有很大机会拍成剧集。但唉，我们没有被选中。于是我又回到了洛杉矶。在经历了接连的拒绝之后，我对表演感到相当沮丧。我决定把精力集中在写作上，把表演暂时搁置。几周过去了，我对倾向于写作的决定感觉很好。然后我接到了一个改变一切的电话。
I was working the box office at iOS when I got a call on my flip phone. Remember those? It was a number I didn't recognize, so I let it go to voicemail. As it turns out, it was from Allison Jones' office. The producers of the office wanted to see me again for a new role, the Prickly Lady in Accounting. Allison told me the creative team thought I was right for the world of Dunder Mifflin, just not quite right for Pam.
我正在iOS售票处工作时，我的翻盖手机响了。还记得那些吗？那是一个我不认识的号码，所以我让它转到了语音信箱。原来，那是来自艾莉森·琼斯办公室的电话。办公室的制片人想再次见我，为了一个新角色，会计部门的刺头女士。艾莉森告诉我创作团队认为我适合邓德米夫林的世间，只是不太适合演潘。
This time there was no big room full of producers, it was just the director Ken Quapas, Phyllis, and the tripod. I was told to come in wearing something drab, my hair plain, and with little to no makeup. Apparently, the Prickly Lady in Accounting was no fashion plate. I wore a light blue turtleneck sweater with a gray cardigan and black pants, pulled my hair back in a low ponytail, and left my face bare. I channeled all my sass and I got the part. And I was pretty sure that the Prickly Accountant would be an easier role for my mom to talk
这次没有坐满制片人的大房间，只有导演肯·夸帕斯、菲莉丝和一个三脚架。我被告知要穿得暗淡朴素地来，头发梳得普普通通，几乎不化妆或者化淡妆。显然，会计部门的刺头女士不是个时尚达人。我穿了一件浅蓝色高领毛衣搭配灰色开衫和黑色裤子，把头发扎成低马尾，素面朝天。我将我所有的厚脸皮都激发出来了，然后我得到了这个角色。而且我相当确认为我妈来说，在她的女士圣经学习班上聊那个挑逗的发廊前台，比起聊这个刺头会计要容易得多。所以一切都解决了。
about at her lady's Bible study than the lustful salon receptionist. So everything worked out. I am so grateful to Greg for getting me in that room on November 17th. That moment changed my life forever, and little did I know, the gal that was cast in the role of Pam would become my best friend forever. Before we started taping the first episode, Ken Quapas suggested we all personalize our desks. I loved this idea.
我非常感谢格雷格在11月17日把我带进那个房间。那个时刻永远改变了我的人生，而我当时并不知道，那个被选中扮演潘的女孩将成为我一生的挚友。在我们开始拍摄第一集之前，肯·夸帕斯建议我们每个人都个性化自己的办公桌。我很喜欢这个主意。
Because of my real-life office experience, I had very strong feelings about the types of supplies a receptionist should have on their desk. The invitation to personalize my workspace made me very excited. Ken also suggested John Krasinski and I spend some time getting to know each other outside of work. Have lunch, have coffee, create a rapport was the suggestion, as it will translate on screen. This is common for actors who are cast in a new project together.
由于我现实生活中的办公室经验，我对前台桌上应该有什么类型的办公用品有着强烈的看法。个性化我的办公空间的邀请让我非常兴奋。肯还建议我和约翰·卡拉辛斯基花点时间在工作之外了解彼此。建议是一起吃午饭、喝咖啡、建立默契，因为这会转化为银幕上的表现。这对于一起被选入新项目的演员来说很常见。
It's key to try and get to know the people you're going to be pretending to be in a relationship with so you don't seem like total strangers on screen. For example, during rehearsals for my job on ABC's Splitting Up Together, Oliver Hudson and I spent two days hanging out with the three children who would play our kids on the show. Like real parents, we sat reading each other bits of news articles off our phones while the kids wrestled. When I did the movie Hall Pass, I had drinks with Owen Wilson who was playing my husband.
关键是要试图了解那些你要和他们假装谈恋爱的人，这样你们在银幕上看起来才不会像是完全的陌生人。例如，在我为ABC的《分道扬镳》工作期间的排练中，奥利弗·哈德森和我花了两天时间与将在剧中扮演我们孩子的三个孩子一起闲逛。就像真正的父母一样，当孩子们在摔跤时，我们坐在一起从手机上互相宣读新闻文章的片段。当我拍电影《放通行证》时，我跟扮演我丈夫的欧文·威尔逊喝过酒。
Incidentally, I did not meet up with Scott Wolf before rubbing Charlie and, well, you already know how that worked out. Note, Scott Wolf is a delightful human being and I adore him. It is not our fault the show didn't go. We were fantastic. And I couldn't forget what Steven Merchant had said, that John and I, virtual strangers, were to be the heart of the show. So, one night after rehearsals, we decided to kill two birds with one stone.
顺便说一句，我在揉搓查理之前没有和斯科特·沃尔夫见面，嗯，你们已经知道结果如何了。注意，斯科特·沃尔夫是一个令人愉快的可爱人类，我崇拜他。节目没能播出不是我们的错。我们棒极了。而且我不能忘记斯蒂芬·莫昌特说过的话，我和约翰这两个实际上是陌生人的人，将成为节目的核心。所以，排练结束后的一天晚上，我们决定一箭双雕。
John Krasinski and I went to a nearby office supply store and shopped for things to decorate our desks. I got a label maker, message pad, message sorter, daily calendar, file folders, multicolored sticky notes. The list goes on and on. I left with two bags of supplies. I think John got a tape dispenser and maybe some post-it notes. The whole time we were shopping, we just kept talking about how excited we were to start
约翰·卡拉辛斯基和我去了一家附近的办公用品店，采购装饰办公桌的东西。我买了一个标签机、留言便签本、留言分类器、日程日历、文件夹、彩色便利贴。清单还在继续，没完没了。我提着两袋用品离开了。我想约翰买了一个胶带座，可能还有一些便利贴。我们购物的整个过程中，我们一直在谈论我们开始
shooting. We wanted to do everything we could to go from pilot to series. John also shared about moving from New York and the adjustment to living in Los Angeles. I was happy to learn that we were both pretty boring people in a good way. He felt stable. He had a good work ethic and he was funny. We laughed a lot. I could tell he was going to be a good acting partner.
拍摄的兴奋心情。我们想尽一切努力从试播集走向整季剧集。约翰还分享了从纽约搬来以及适应洛杉矶生活的经历。我很开心得知我们俩在好的方面都挺无聊的。他给人感觉很稳定。他有良好的职业道德，而且他很有趣。我们笑了很多。我看得出他会是一个很好的表演搭档。
Greg had encouraged us to think about our characters and their back stories, so when it came to my desk area, I tried to imagine what a stuffy lady in accounting might bring to the office. I brought in a photo of my grandmother Lena and me. In the picture, my eyes are closed, but I am smiling. It makes me laugh that Angela Martin would choose to frame a photo where her eyes are closed. Like, perhaps that was just the best one of the bunch?
格雷格鼓励我们思考我们的角色和他们的背景故事，所以当谈到我的办公桌区域时，我试图想象一个会计部门里迂腐的女士可能会给办公室带什么。我带了一张我和祖母莉娜的照片。在照片里，我的眼睛闭着，但我正在笑。安吉拉·马丁会选择一张自己闭着眼睛的照片，这让我觉得很好笑。比如，也许那就是那堆里面最好的一张？
I also brought in a day planner. I felt like Angela Martin would have an appointment book and it would be very comprehensive. The set dressers put a blue ceramic cat paper clip holder on my desk. The cat's left ear was slightly chipped and I loved that little detail. It looked like a knick-knack you would get from a garage sale in a small town. That cat paper clip holder did a lot to inform who Angela Martin was. It was clear to me that she must love cats and that she didn't need fancy new things to make her happy.
我还带了一个日程规划本。我觉得安吉拉·马丁会有一本预约本，而且会非常详尽。布景师在我的桌上放了一个蓝色陶瓷猫咪回形针夹。猫的左耳稍微有点缺口，我喜欢这个小细节。它看起来像你在一个小镇的旧货出售中买到的那种小摆设。那只猫咪回形针夹很大程度上塑造了安吉拉·马丁是个什么样的人。对我来说很显然，她一定很喜欢猫，而且她不需要昂贵的新东西来让自己快乐。
She was too humble for fancy, in a judgmental way, of course. People ask us all the time what we took from the set the day we wrapped the series. And I took that cat paper clip holder. It sits on my desk at home to this day. Walking onto the set for our first day of shooting, I was so nervous. I'd left my house at 5 a.m. for what was a 45-minute commute. I made myself a song mix I affectionately titled Songs of Scranton. I drank coffee and bounced along the freeway.
她太谦虚而不需要奢华，当然是用一种评判的眼光。人们总是问我们在剧集杀青那天从片场拿了什么。而我拿走了那个猫咪回形针夹。直到今天，它依然坐在我家里的书桌上。走进我们第一天拍摄的片场时，我太紧张了。我早上5点钟就离开了家，车程本来是45分钟。我给自己做了一张混音带，我亲切地称之为“斯克兰顿之歌”。我喝着咖啡，在高速公路上蹦蹦跳跳。
I tried to imagine I was driving to my real job at a real paper company in Scranton, Pennsylvania. When I arrived, I was taken to Wardrobe. There were a lot of very quick introductions to various other cast members who were coming and going between Wardrobe hair and makeup. It was then that I first met Leslie David Baker, who would soon be known to many as Stanley Hudson. He was so warm, friendly, and open that watching him switch over to Stanley the checked out grump was hilarious. Our director had requested that everyone be on set and add our desks at 7.30 a.m. sharp.
我试图想象我是开车去宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿一家真正的纸业公司去上真班。当我到达时，我被带到了服装间。有很多非常快速的介绍，对象是在服装、发型和化妆之间来来往往的其他演员。正是在那时，我第一次遇到了莱斯利·大卫·贝克，他很快就会被许多人称为斯坦利·哈逊。他非常热情、友好和坦率，看着他切换成那个出工不出力、满腹牢骚的斯坦利真是太搞笑了。我们的导演要求每个人都在早上7点30分准时到达片场并坐在各自的桌子旁。
He asked us all to pretend to work while the film crew recorded us. He wanted to capture us like real documentarians would, because this was the convention of the show. We were real office workers being filmed by a documentary film crew. When we were all in place, the set was cleared of all crew members except for the camera operator, boom operator, and director. They started rolling, and it all felt so real. It was very quiet at first.
他要求我们假装工作，同时电影摄制组录制我们。他想把我们拍得像真正的纪录片工作者那样，因为这就是该剧的模式。我们是被纪录片摄制组拍摄的真正的办公室职员。当我们都各就各位后，片场除了摄像师、杆式麦克风操作员和导演外，清空了所有的剧组成员。他们开始拍摄，这一切感觉太真实了。一开始非常安静。
Then Phyllis and Leslie started improvising fake sales calls. I started to answer the phone and transfer calls. A lot of the shots you see in the opening credits of the show are from that very first morning. I was also a bundle of nerves that first day. My call time to set was 4.30 a.m., so I didn't get much sleep the night before. We were filming in an empty office building in Culver City, California. The building was only two stories and we filmed on the second floor.
然后菲莉丝和莱斯利开始即兴编造虚假的销售电话。我开始接听电话并转接电话。你在该剧片头字幕中看到的许多镜头都来自那个清晨。第一天我也紧张得要命。我到片场的通告时间是早上4点30分，所以我前一晚没怎么睡觉。我们在加利福尼亚州卡尔弗城的一栋空办公室大楼里拍摄。这栋楼只有两层，我们在二楼拍摄。
There was an empty sound stage next to the main building where the hair and makeup team was set up. It was cold and dark when I arrived, with only one small space heater in that big, drafty room. We huddled around it and waited our turn. Our director had instructed the hair and makeup departments to keep our looks very simple. I was given a loose French braid and some powder and lip balm. That's all.
主楼旁边有一个空的摄影棚，美发和化妆团队就在那里搭建。我到达时又冷又黑，那个巨大而透风的房间里只有一个小型空间取暖器。我们挤在它周围等待轮到我们。我们的导演指示发型和化妆部门将我们的造型保持得非常简单。我梳了一个松散的法式编发，打了一点粉底，涂了润唇膏。仅此而已。
The wardrobe department asked me to bring the clothes and shoes I had worn to my audition for Angela Martin, so I actually wore my own clothes and the pilot. With barely any hair and makeup and no wardrobe fitting, it didn't take much time for me to get ready. I walked onto the set early and realized I wasn't sure where I was supposed to sit. Ken Quapas must have seen me looking around sort of lost. He came over to me and told me I'd be sitting in the corner in what would become the accounting department.
服装部门要求我带上我为安吉拉·马丁试镜时穿的衣服和鞋子，所以我实际上在试播集中穿的是我自己的衣服。几乎没有什么发型和化妆，也没有服装试穿，我没花多少时间就准备好了。我很早就走进了片场，意识到我不确定自己该坐在哪里。肯·夸帕斯一定看到我四处张望，有点迷茫。他朝我走来，告诉我我会坐在后来成为会计部门的角落里。
He walked me over to introduce me to my deskmates. There I found seated at the desk, right next to me, Oscar Nunez. I had known Oscar for years. We first met at the groundlings and then went on to perform together in a sketch comedy show called Hot Towel. I played a horny boy scout and Oscar a crazy professor. I was so thrilled to see my old friend that I yelled out, holy crap, Oscar! Neither of us knew that the other had been cast.
他带着我去把我介绍给我的同桌们。我在那里发现坐在我桌子正旁边的是奥斯卡·努涅斯。我认识奥斯卡好几年了。我们最初是在小剧团（The Groundlings）认识的，后来一起在名为《热毛巾》的素描喜剧秀中演出。我扮演一个好色的童子军，奥斯卡扮演一个疯狂的教授。看到我的老朋友，我激动得大喊：“天哪，奥斯卡！”我们俩都不知道对方也被选中了。
This was in the antiquated times before everything everyone is doing and saying was posted online. You could still be surprised by things. Imagine that! One of the very first photos I took on the office set was of the accounting department. We took the photo and character and it cracks me up that even in the first week, Oscar, Kevin and Angela were clearly formed people. We already knew who we were in the world of the show. I think it speaks to how amazing the writing was on the office and also to Allison Jones
这是在古老的时代，在每个人做的事和说的话都被发布到网上之前。你依然能对事情感到惊讶。想象一下！我在办公室片场拍的第一批照片之一就是会计部门。我们在角色中拍了这张照片，这让我觉得很好笑，甚至在第一周，奥斯卡、Kevin和安吉拉就已经是鲜明成型的角色了。我们已经知道我们在剧中的世界里是谁了。我认为这说明了办公室的剧本有多么出色，也说明了艾莉森·琼斯
and her gift for assembling acting ensembles. I'll never forget seeing Angela pop her head up over the partition between our desks to introduce herself. Her face barely made it over the edge as she said hello in her bubbly Texas twang. She was instantly funny, upbeat and kind. I liked her immediately. She was clearly nothing like her character Angela Martin, which shows what a great actress she is.
以及她组建演员阵容的天赋。我永远不会忘记看到安吉拉把头从我们办公桌之间的隔板上探出来介绍她自己。她的脸勉强露过边缘，用她那活泼的德克萨斯腔说了一声你好。她立刻变得滑稽、乐观、善良。我立刻就喜欢上了她。她显然一点也不像她的角色安吉拉·马丁，这表明她是一个多么伟大的演员。
In addition to our chats over the partition, Angela would talk my ear off in the hair and makeup room and she would keep talking as we walked to the snack table and then to set. I often joke that I had no choice but to become friends with Angela because she wouldn't stop talking to me. I was so grateful for her. I was nervous and she was an instant comfort. My first memory of Jenna is hearing a little dainty sneeze come from behind the partition next to my desk.
除了隔板上的聊天外，安吉拉还会在发化妆间里喋喋不休地对我说个不停，当我们走向零食桌然后走向片场时，她还会继续说下去。我经常开玩笑说我别无选择，只能和安吉拉成为朋友，因为她一直对我说个不停。我很感激她。我很紧张，而她立刻给我带来了安慰。我对珍娜的第一个记忆是听到办公桌隔板后面传来一声娇小的喷嚏声。
It reminded me of my neighbor's peek-a-boo sneezing. It was adorable. She sat directly behind me and was physically the closest gal to me on set. Jenna seemed shy, but then again I am super chatty and I probably scared her. I can do that to people. Every day that first week I'd get up on my tippy toes and pop my head over and chat. Those desk partition chats became our daily habit for the next nine years. The whole week seemed to speed by so fast.
这让我想起了我邻居的躲猫猫式喷嚏。太可爱了。她就坐在我正后方，在物理上是片场离我最近的女孩。珍娜看起来很害羞，但话又说回来，我超级健谈，我可能把她吓到了。我对人是做得出这种事的。第一周的每天，我都会踮起脚尖把头探过去聊天。那些办公桌隔板聊天成了我们接下来九年的日常习惯。整周时间似乎过得太快了。
Before we knew it, the pilot was done and we all went home to wait the almost three months it took to learn if our show would make it to series. Shortly after we'd filmed the pilot, I went to London for a friend's wedding. While I was there, I reached out to Ricky and Steven to see if they were able to meet. I don't know where I got the courage to call, but since I'd basically been unemployed since shooting the pilot for the office, this was the one potentially exciting thing I had in my life. I wanted to milk it for all it was worth.
不知不觉中，试播集完成了，我们都回家等待那几乎三个月的漫长时间，以了解我们的剧集是否会被选中做成一整季。拍完试播集后不久，我去了伦敦参加一个朋友的婚礼。当我在那里时，我联系了瑞奇和斯蒂芬，看看他们是否能见面。我不知道我从哪里借来的勇气打这个电话，但自从为《办公室》拍完试播集后我基本就处于失业状态，这是我生活中唯一一件可能令人兴奋的事情。我想把它物尽其用。
They agreed to host me for lunch at the exclusive Groucho Club. The Groucho is a famed private club for comedians and I couldn't believe I was there. I don't like to think too much about that lunch because I'm certain I sounded like a raving idiot going on and on and praising their genius nonstop. They must have taken pity on me because they even agreed to post for a photo afterward. After the lunch, I was sitting on the tube reading a discarded UK TV guide. Inside was an article about the casting of the American version of the office. How crazy is that?
他们同意在独家的古罗乔俱乐部招待我吃午饭。古罗乔是喜剧演员著名的私人俱乐部，我简直不敢相信自己会在那里。我不想对那顿午饭想太多，因为我确信我听起来像个狂热的白痴，滔滔不绝地赞美他们的天才，从不停歇。他们一定是可怜我，甚至同意在饭后摆姿势拍张照。午饭后，我坐在地铁里看着一份被丢弃的英国电视指南。里面有一篇关于美国版《办公室》选角的文章。这有多疯狂？
The article was not positive. It said, quote, the chances of NBC actually matching wits with the original are about as good as finding a designated driver at a Wembley football match, end quote. It included photos of the original cast members alongside photos of each of us from the American version. The article basically went on to break down how we were ill suited for the roles and would ruin the show. It ended by predicting our show would be as palatable as, quote, a plate of mushy peas,
这篇文章并不积极。它写道，“NBC真正能与原版机智抗衡的机会，大约跟在温布利足球赛上找到一个指定代驾的几率差不多”，引号结束。它附上了原版演员的照片以及我们美国版每个人的照片。这篇文章基本上接着分析了我们如何不适合这些角色并会毁了这部剧。它以预测我们的剧集会像“一盘烂糊糊的豌豆”一样难以下咽而告终，
end quote. How did I feel about this? I'll tell you. My photo was in a magazine. I was blown away. It was the first time I'd ever been in a magazine. I tore out the article and tucked it into my purse. For years, I saved every press clipping about our show, even if I wasn't mentioned at all.
引号结束。我对这个有什么感觉？我来告诉你。我的照片上杂志了。我惊呆了。这是我第一次上杂志。我撕下那篇文章，把它塞进我的钱包里。多年来，我保存了关于我们节目的每一篇剪报，即使根本没有提到我。
I can't explain it exactly, but from the very beginning, this show felt special. It felt different from the rest. I wanted to keep a record of every moment, even the ones where we were compared to mushy peas. About two months later, Greg called and said he'd finished editing the pilot episode and sent it off to the network. He wanted to share it with the cast. If the folks at UK TV Guide were right, it would be the only episode of the American
我无法确切解释，但从一开始，这个节目就感觉很特别。它感觉与众不同。我想记录下每一个时刻，甚至是我们被拿来和烂糊糊的豌豆作比较的那些时刻。大约两个月后，格雷格打电话说他完成了试播集的剪辑并寄给了电视网。他想把它分享给演员阵容。如果《英国电视指南》的人是对的，那将是美国版《办公室》制作的唯一一集，所以我们想要庆祝。我主动提出举办一个观影派对。
version of The Office ever produced, so we wanted to celebrate. I offered to host a viewing party. It's something that would become an ongoing tradition when the show was on the air. We'd switch houses each week, watching it together, but this was the first. Everyone gathered at my house. I moved the furniture around in an effort to accommodate everyone, but there were so many people that folks were sitting on the floor, including Steve Carell. We ordered pizza and got set to watch.
当剧集播出时，这将成为一项持续的传统。我们每周轮流去对方家里，一起看，但这还是第一次。大家都聚集在我家里。我把家具移来移去以容纳所有人，但人实在太多了，以至于人们都坐在地板上，包括史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我们订了披萨，准备观看。
At first, you couldn't get your DVD player to work. Yes, I was mortified. Everyone was in my house, sitting on my floor, waiting to see this show that we'd worked so hard on. It was so much pressure. After some colorful language and trying a few different plugs, you changed the batteries in your remote and got it working. It saved.
起初，你的DVD播放器无法工作。是的，我尴尬极了。每个人都在我家，坐在我的地板上，等着看这部我们付出了如此多心血的节目。压力太大了。经过一些带有颜色的语言和尝试了几个不同的插头后，你换了遥控器的电池，它终于工作了。它得救了。
And if I remember correctly, we watched it twice. We all told Greg how much we loved it, and we did. We felt good about what we had created. Greg told us he had no idea which way the network was leaning and that we'd have to wait another month to find out. A month? How in the world was I going to fill the next 30 days without going out of my mind? I decided to stock more original office cast members.
如果我没记错的话，我们看了两遍。我们都告诉格雷格我们有多喜欢它，我们确实很喜欢。我们对自己创造的东西感觉良好。格雷格告诉我们，他不知道电视网倾向于哪一边，我们还得再等一个月才知道。一个月？我到底要怎么度过接下来的30天而不发疯呢？我决定去骚扰更多的原版办公室演员。
My manager, Naomi Odenkirk, had a client who was shooting a pilot with Lucy Davis. I went to the taping and met her afterward. She was bubbly and smiley. She told me how the office had changed her life and wished me all the same success. I asked for a photo, of course. Then I went home and waited. And waited. And waited.
我的经纪人南娜·奥登柯克有一个客户正在和露西·戴维斯拍试播集。我去现场探班，并在事后见到了她。她活泼爱笑。她告诉我《办公室》是如何改变了她的人生，并祝我取得同样的成功。我当然要求合影。然后我回家等待。等待。再等待。
During our month wait, I went home to visit my family's farm in Texas. It's about 300 acres in the middle of nowhere. My dad would wake me up early in the morning to feed the cows. When I wasn't helping my dad, I was helping my mom and grandmother shelf cons. Hollywood felt very far away, and I was thankful for the distraction. While I was there, I got the news that NBC had picked up five more episodes of The Office. We were officially a series. My whole family was so excited.
在我们等待的一个月里，我回家去德克萨斯州的家族农场探亲。那是一个位于荒郊野岭的约300英亩的农场。我爸爸一大早就会叫醒我去喂牛。当我没帮爸爸时，我就帮妈妈和奶奶腌罐头。好莱坞感觉非常遥远，我很感激有这个转移注意力的机会。我在那里时，接到了消息说NBC又订购了五集《办公室》。我们正式成为一部剧了。我的全家人都兴奋极了。
They knew what a long journey this had been for me. Mom said we should celebrate, so she put on a pot roast, a pot roast, and homemade rolls. Birdie Jo, that's my mom's name, was going all out. Some meals you remember for your whole life. And that was one of them for me. Good news and a good pot roast, a celebration indeed. When I got the call that the show was getting picked up, I screamed. My very pragmatic agents congratulated me, and then, I guess, to temper my expectations,
他们知道对我来说这段旅程有多长。妈妈说我们应该庆祝，于是她炖了一锅牛肉，炖牛肉，还有自制卷饼。伯蒂·乔（那是我妈妈的名字）全力以赴了。有些饭菜你一辈子都会记得。对我来说那就是其中之一。好消息加上好炖牛肉，确实值得庆祝。当我接到剧集被续订的电话时，我尖叫了。我非常务实的经纪人们向我道贺，然后，我猜是为了压低我的期望，
told me that five episodes was a very small order, and it indicated very little confidence in the show. They were basically saying, have fun, but don't spend all your money in one place. In fact, my agents continued to send me other pilot scripts while we were shooting season one of The Office. A recurring theme of our early years was people explaining to us how our show would never really make it. I told them I was simply excited to be employed for now.
告诉我五集的订单非常小，这表明对该剧缺乏信心。他们基本上是在说，玩得开心，但别把钱都花在一个地方。事实上，在我们拍摄《办公室》第一季期间，我的经纪人们继续给我发其他试播集的剧本。我们早年生活的一个反复出现的主题是，人们向我们解释我们的节目永远不会真正成功。我告诉他们，我只是很高兴现在有工作可做。
I couldn't wait to get back to work with everyone again. Our pilot had been a direct adaptation of the British pilot script, but the network wanted the next five episodes to be original. Greg assembled a staff of writers to start breaking down stories for the first all original episodes. That group was Mindy Kaling, Mike Schurr, and BJ Novak, plus three consultants, Paul Lieberstein, Larry Wilmore, and Lester Lewis. One of the first stories they came up with was based on a real life experience of their
我迫不及待地想回去和大家一起工作。我们的试播集是对英国试播集剧本的直接改编，但电视网希望接下来的五集是原创的。格雷格组建了一支编剧团队，开始为第一批全原创剧集构思故事。那群人是敏迪·卡灵、迈克·舒尔和B·J·诺瓦克，再加上三位顾问保罗·利伯斯坦、拉里·威尔莫尔和莱斯特·刘易斯。他们想出的第一个故事之一是基于他们的编剧助理汤姆·黄的真实生活经历。
writer's assistant, Tom Huang. When Tom was in college, he took a class in which they did an exercise where they had to put note cards on their foreheads with different ethnicities, and then they had to go around and regard one another as that ethnicity using stereotypes. This turned into Diversity Day. BJ Novak, who was only 25 years old at the time, was tasked with writing the episode, which the writing staff nicknamed the pilot after the pilot. It would establish what the audience could expect from the American version of the office
当汤姆在大学时，他上过一门课，其中有一个练习，他们必须把写有不同族裔的便签贴在额头上，然后他们必须四处走动，并使用刻板印象将彼此视为那个族裔。这演变成了“多元化日”。当时只有25岁的B·J·诺瓦克被指派编写这一集，编剧团队给这一集起了个绰号叫“试播集之后的试播集”。它将确立观众对美版《办公室》未来的期望。对我们来说幸运的是，B·J·成功了。
moving forward. Good thing for us, BJ nailed it. The morning we filmed Michael Scott's Diversity Day seminar, the props department handed us our note cards and showed us how to place them on our foreheads. They were taped to our foreheads at 7.30 a.m., and we wore those cards for 12 hours. We only took them off at lunchtime. Hours went by and we forgot all about them. Mine said Jamaica.
我们拍摄迈克尔·斯科特的多元化日研讨会的那个早晨，道具部门把便签交给我们，并向我们展示了如何把它们贴在额头上。它们在早上7点30分被贴在我们的额头上，我们戴着那些纸条长达12个小时。我们只在午饭时把它们取下来。几个小时过去了，我们完全把它们忘了。我的上面写着牙买加。
I wish I had taken a picture of us on our snack break, imagining seeing the cast eating nachos with these ridiculous cards on their foreheads. Standing by the salsa bar was Jenna, with Jewish tape to her forehead, talking to Brian with Italian tape to his. By the end of the day, the double-stick tape had left skinny, rectangular bald spots on our foreheads. When it was worth it, the cast was completely in sync. All our reactions every moment felt perfect.
我真希望我拍了一张我们在吃点心休息时的照片，想象一下看到演员们额头上顶着这些荒谬的纸条吃玉米片。站在莎莎酱吧旁边的是珍娜，额头上贴着犹太人，正和贴着意大利人的布莱恩聊天。到了一天结束时，双面胶在我们的额头上留下了细长的、矩形的秃斑。虽然很值，但演员阵容完全合拍。我们每一刻的反应都感觉完美。
I remember looking around that conference room and thinking, oh my god, if we can just get people to watch the show, we're going to be a hit. From the very beginning, it felt like the cast of the office had a group mind. Bear with me, but this group mind idea is from the improv world, and I always relate back to that. By group mind, I mean we had this shared comedic collective consciousness. When you are performing improv as a group, no single person leads. The goal is to find your way together, listening, reacting, and being in the moment.
我记得环顾那个会议室，心想，哦天哪，如果我们能让人们看这个节目，我们一定会大获成功的。从一开始，感觉《办公室》的演员阵容就有着一种集体心智。请原谅我，但这个集体心智的概念来自即兴表演界，我总是把它联系回去。所谓集体心智，是指我们拥有这种共享的喜剧集体意识。当你作为一个团队进行即兴表演时，没有人是单独领导的。目标是通过倾听、反应和处于当下，一起找到出路。
I felt like our cast had this kind of comedic mind meld. The magic came from a combination of great writing and smart casting, but I think it was also due to the fact that the original cast shared a lot of history with one another. You already know that I knew Greg by marriage, and as a result, Paul as well, and that I had performed with Oscar in sketch comedy shows. But I also knew Kate Flannery our saucy Meredith. For years, Kate and I performed improv together at I.O. West. But wait, there's more.
我觉得我们的演员阵容有这种喜剧心智融通。这种魔力来自于伟大的剧本和明智的选角的结合，但我认为这也是因为原演员阵容彼此分享了大量的历史。你已经知道我和格雷格因为婚姻关系而认识，因此也认识保罗，而且我和奥斯卡一起在素描喜剧秀中演出过。但我还认识凯特·弗兰内里，我们风骚的梅雷迪思。多年来，凯特和我在I.O. West一起表演即兴喜剧。但是等等，还有呢。
Jenna and I had been living a few blocks apart as struggling artists, using the same grocery store but never met. Jenna, Phyllis, and director Ken Quapas are all from St. Louis. Brian Baumgartner and Rayne Wilson had done regional theater together. Then there's the fact that BJ Novak and John Krasinski were childhood friends in Newton, Massachusetts, and even played in the same Little League Baseball division. Do you see what I mean here? For the most part, we were a group of strangers, yet somehow it felt like destiny that we would
珍娜和我作为苦苦挣扎的艺术家，住在几个街区之外，去同一家杂货店却从未相遇。珍娜、菲莉丝和导演肯·夸帕斯都来自圣路易斯。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳和雷恩·威尔逊一起演过地区剧院。然后还有这样一个事实：B·J·诺瓦克和约翰·卡拉辛斯基是马萨诸塞州牛顿市的童年朋友，甚至在同一个小联盟棒球赛区打过球。你明白我的意思了吗？在很大程度上，我们是一群陌生人，但不知何故，我们注定要在这个节目中聚在一起，感觉就像命中注定。
all come together on this show. You take these people whose lives have been crisscrossing for years and you put them in a tiny little office, write them amazing scripts, and it was comedic lightning in a bottle. It's impossible to predict if a television show or movie project will be a success. And with the office, we spent the first two seasons believing we could be canceled at any moment. No one looked at this group of people and said, bingo, we've got a hit television show on our hands.
你把这些生活轨迹交织了多年的把他们放在一个小小的办公室里，为他们写出精彩的剧本，这就是瓶中的喜剧闪电。要预测一个电视剧或电影项目是否会成功是不可能的。而在《办公室》，我们在前两季里一直以为我们随时可能被取消。没有人看着这群人说：“宾果，我们手头有一部热门电视剧。”
But what you did feel, standing on that set altogether, was magic. You could feel the chemistry of these people that Greg had so masterfully gathered together. And that includes our writers, directors, and crew. Every person on set was essential. It's just as Angela said, it was as if we'd been crisscrossing one another our whole lives up until that point just for this purpose. Every role we hadn't gotten, every show before that didn't go, made it so we were now together for this one.
但你所能感受到的，是站在那个片场的所有人身上感受到的魔力。你能感受到格雷格巧妙聚集在一起的这些人的化学反应。这包括我们的编剧、导演和剧组。片场每个人都至关重要。就像安吉拉说的，就好像我们在那之前的一生中一直在彼此交错，只为了这个目的。我们没有得到每一个角色、之前没有播出的每一个节目，都使得我们现在为了这个聚在一起。
We had no idea if fans would like the show or how long the magic would last. We were all just grateful to be there creating something together. Thanks so much for listening to a little bit of our audiobook, The Office BFFs. You can buy the audiobook anywhere you buy audiobooks. And on the audiobook, we have some really fun friends who pop in for, I don't know, what would you call it, surprise audio tidbits? I just want to say Ed Helms plays the banjo. And Creed Bratton wrote a special song that kicks off the whole audiobook, Rainn Wilson.
我们不知道粉丝是否会喜欢这个节目，也不知道这魔力能持续多久。我们大家只是感激能在一起创造一些东西。非常感谢收听我们的一小部分有声书《办公室闺蜜》。你可以在任何买有声书的地方买到这本书。在有声书中，我们有一些非常有趣的盆友会突然冒出来，我不知道，你会怎么称呼它，惊喜音频花絮？我只想说埃德·赫尔姆斯弹了班卓琴。克里德·布拉顿写了一首特别的歌来开启整个有声书，还有雷恩·威尔逊。
He wrote and recorded a foreword just for the audiobook. Yeah, it's not in the hardback. Kate Flannery sings us a little jingle. And then we have all of these great moments with Steve Carell, Ryan Baumgartner, Oscar Nunez, Ellie Kemper, and Jennifer Garner. Thanks so much for listening, you guys. We hope you have a great day. Bye.
他专门为有声书写并录制了一个前言。是的，精装本里没有这个。凯特·弗兰内里为我们唱了一段小歌。然后我们有所有这些与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、瑞安·鲍姆加特纳、奥斯卡·努涅斯、艾莉·肯珀和詹妮弗·加纳在一起的精彩时刻。非常感谢你们的收听。祝你们有美好的一天。再见。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾insley·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要获得Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。